we have a problem now that AI is here it
seems like anybody with a computer
access and internet access can write a
book but while some people think that
writing with AI is just as simple as
pushing a button it really isn't that
simple and honestly most books turn out
terrible if you do that but that's only
if you don't understand the basics of
what makes a good book as well as good
prompting techniques in order to get the
AI to write like a bestselling author
and so in this video I'm going to show
you how to write a good book using AI in
[Music]
2025 if you're new here my name is Jason
Hamilton I'm the nerdy novelist I've
been a self-published author for over
eight years now and three of those years
I actually worked at kindlepreneur one
of the largest resources to learn about
self-publishing and writing and
marketing your books I've written about
20 titles to my name and I built this
channel because I saw a lot of AI Bros
out there talking about how to write a
book with AI and it was very clear to me
as an experienced author that none of
them had ever written a book in their
life so in this video I'm going to walk
you through all of the steps to write a
good book with AI both fiction and
non-fiction because they actually follow
a very similar process we're going to
cover the tools that you're going to
need we're going to talk about two
different methods one for Discovery
writers and one for outliners and I'll
walk you through all of the steps in
that process so let's start by talking
about the tools that you would need to
actually write a good book with AI my
general recommendation for tools is to
have one specialized tool that is
specifically geared to write long form
fiction or non-fiction and then
complement that with one chatbot and
I'll get into what those are in the
second but they are the simplest
interface and they're not as adaptable
and all of that but sometimes having
simple is better and so combining a more
specialized tool with a chatbot I think
is a really good idea now the most
common chat Bots out there are chat gbt
Claude and Gemini there are others as
well but those are likely going to be
the three that you want because they
house the most power ful models you
don't have to have all three you can
just choose one but with the one that
you choose I would go for the $20 tier
in order to get a little bit more use
out of the AI and to realize that you
are making an investment in your author
business and sometimes having a little
money that you spending can be extremely
motivating to actually use that money
wisely and get writing my personal
favorite out of the bunch is Claude but
really both chat GPT and Gem and I have
made some impressive strides lately that
have upgraded their models significantly
and I find them all three of them really
to be sufficient the purpose of having a
chatbot at your disposal is to have a
catchall for everything that's not
directly related to writing long form
fiction you're going to find in your
writing Journey that you're going to
have a lot of use cases that just don't
quite fit into a specialized tool the
specialized tools can be amazing at
helping you write the book but let's say
you just wanted to brainstorm ideas or
uh develop a character or brainstorm
some World building ideas uh what
whatever you can think of sometimes
those things don't fit neatly into a
specialized tool and so having a chatbot
that's more versatile albeit simpler is
a good idea to have for the specialized
tools there are three that generally
take the the top tier in the writing
World there is PSE sudoite Raptor right
and novel crafter PSE sudoite is good
for fiction I wouldn't really use it for
non-fiction and honestly it's not my
favorite of the bunch but it does have a
specialized large language model that is
actually really good at the fiction
writing process so I wouldn't discount
it entirely I'll be sure to do a more
detailed comparison later on then we
have Raptor right the great thing about
Raptor Rite is that it is free for the
software you still have to pay through
an API uh through open router in order
to get your air written words but that
is usually not a very expensive process
and the great thing about Raptor right
is that it's very simple people that are
just starting out with AI might prefer
Raptor write to start with because it is
a very simple process it'll teach you
the basics of writing with AI it might
also be a better option for Discovery
writers who don't want all of the bells
and whistles they just kind of want to
focus on the next part of their story
and not have to worry about everything
else and then there's novel crafter now
novel crafter is my personal favorite of
the bunch it's kind of the Adobe
Photoshop of these specialized tools
because it can do a huge amount of
things not just for writing fiction or
non-fiction I know people that are using
it to write uh tabletop game campaigns
for things like Dungeons and Dragons and
of the bunch it's definitely the most
versatile tool which is why I like it
however it is a little bit more more
complicated and takes a little bit more
of a learning curve to get into it it
does also have a small expense in
addition to the AI words that you're
going to be pulling in through an API
just like Raptor Wright it also has a
small monthly expense on top of that but
it's usually it's not that expensive
compared to other tools like pseudo
write or even compared to the chat Bots
which are all $20 a month generally
speaking you're probably going to be
spending less than $20 a month using
novel crafter for demonstration purposes
in this video I'm going to be using a
combination of Novel crafter with chat
GPT since chat gbt is the most
well-known tool but keep in mind that
you could do a similar process to what
I'm going to be showing you with any of
the chat Bots and with any of the
specialized tools that I've mentioned so
with that let's get to Method one on how
to write a book with AI so this first
method of writing is actually the
simplest and one of the easiest to get
started with so you might want to try it
to get started for this method I'm only
going to be using one tool that's novel
crafter although you could use a chatbot
for this as well but I find novel
crafter makes this process relatively
simple other tools particularly Raptor
write are very suited for this mode of
writing as well and so you could
absolutely use those tools as well I'm
just going to show it off for you here
in novel crafter in novel crafter you
want to go here to create a novel and
just put in the title of your book here
and your author pen name I'm just going
to actually call this discovery writing
demonstration and hit create novel and
it puts you into the novel crafter
interface here now this is not going to
be a full tutorial on novel crafter I
have other videos that you can check out
that do exactly that but I am going to
show you a few few things just a few
tiny things to set up before you get
started the first thing I would actually
do is I would create a single character
who's going to be your protagonist and
I'll show you why this is important in a
second but to do that over here we make
sure we have codec selected which it is
by default and select new entry
character and we can name this character
whatever we want I'm just going to call
her Candace and we'll just say Candice
is the protagonist she is a police
detective in a small town in the Pacific
Northwest and that's all I'm going to
put in there right for now you could put
a lot more information if you want but I
really want to keep this as simple as
possible so that's all I'm going to put
in there right now just so it knows who
this character Candace is and why she's
important so we're going to just click
out of that and go to this gear icon up
here and once you've clicked on that
you'll see these options at the top that
say metadata writing collaboration and
Export you want to select the one that
says writing and we're going to select
our point of view here so let's say we
actually want this to be first person
point of view from Candace's perspective
we'd hit first person and then we'd
select the character and this is why we
created the character so we could select
her here as the point of view character
we'll also want to specify whether this
should be in past tense or present tense
those are usually the two tenses that
you're going to be using in writing a
novel past tense is the most common but
just so you can kind of see what this
looks like I'm going to select present
tense just for fun and that's all you
need to do so now we've selected the
tense of the story and we've selected
the point of view and this is why having
a specialist tool can be really useful
for you is it allows you to bake into
your prompts things like this the tense
and the point of view otherwise you
would have to include that in your
prompts if I were doing this in chat GPT
I would have to specify every time I
prompted it every time I've created a
new chapter or something I'd have to
specify this is in present tense this is
the first point of view from this
character's perspective and you just
have to include that information all the
time now I don't really need to because
I've selected it here in the settings so
while it's technically possible to do
everything that I'm doing inside of a
chat bot is just more work and that's
why having a specialist tool really kind
of Smooths out that process and makes it
really easy to get going so now up here
at the top we have the plan write chat
and review and for this method of
writing we don't need any of these
except for right so we're going to go to
the right and say add initial scene and
all you have to do to get started and
novel crafter is to do a forward slash
and it will give you the option of a
scene beat or continue writing or a
codex Edition really the only one that I
use regular Al is this one called scene
beat and from here you can say Candice
walks into the police office and slumps
down in her chair someone can tell
something is wrong and asks her what the
matter is and she replies that coffee
machine is broken okay so just a a
standard like opening moment for this
character and then you see this button
here called generate Pros if we click on
that it actually gives us a whole bunch
of different prompts that we can use in
fact I think by default there's only one
here for this particular type of writing
and that is general purpose all of these
others that you see here I've created
myself so before I actually go to
writing this I'll show you a little bit
of how this is done so down here in the
bottom left there's a button called
prompts and from here you can select the
defaults all of these that say system
are defaults they can't be changed but
you'll see I have a lot more here
besides the system prompts and that's
because I like to change the prompts
sometimes the general purpose prompt
gives you options for all of these
different models that you see here any
of these can be used there are actually
more models than this but these are
certainly ones that you could start with
and then also you can go here to
instructions and this is the actual
prompt that it's running and some of
this is going to look a little bit
overwhelming this is why novel crafter
is such a powerful tools because it
gives you a lot more creative freedom
but it basically just gives information
about the characters that we already put
into this character here for Candace it
pulls that in it gives it some style
information it gives it information
about the story so far if there is any
which there isn't in our case this
section looks at the previous words
written and then this section here gives
it the actual instructions so first of
all it pulls in the scene POV which we
specified and it says continue the story
and write about 400 words for the
following instructions and then it pulls
in what we already wrote in the scene
beat section and then it gives it a few
more instructions and then runs the
prompt so if I wanted to run that prompt
I would just come here to generate Pros
general purpose and then it would give
me a list of models that I could choose
from here we could select for instance
3.5 Sonet which I consider to be one of
the better ones and hit go and it's
created the first little bit of our
story now remember this prompt is asking
for only 400 words so if you wanted it
to write a longer section based on what
you put in there you could just modify
that prompt in this case since it's the
system prompt you would have to
duplicate it and then modify that prompt
and then use that one but I like this so
I'm going to hit apply and this is the
most important part of the entire
writing process using this method first
of all let's read a little bit here it
says the fluorescent lights flicker as I
drag my feet across the precinct floor
making my way to my desk so already you
can tell this is written in present
tense it said flicker instead of
flickered and it's in first person point
of view my shoulders slump forward as I
drop into my chair the worn leather
squeaking in protest the stack of case
files on my desk blurs together
everything blurs together without my
morning fuel officer Martinez glanced up
from his computer screen his bushy
eyebrows furrowing looking rough there
detective world ending or something I
let my forehead thk against the desk
worse coffee machine's dead and actually
I like some of the dialogue that we've
gotten here no way the one in the break
room yep won't even turn on but that
thing's ancient been here longer than
both of us combined so there there is
actually some gems in here but this is
the important thing to remember as we're
going through this process is that we
want to go through a validation process
cuz if we were to just come on to the
next beat uh we'd create another scene
beat I would write out what happens and
it would continue it would continue but
this time it would actually look at what
it's written previously and continue on
from there and if we have imperfect text
here or text that does not match the
story as we want it to be it will
continue off of imperfect background
text and so we want to actually go
through this and make sure it's all up
to our standards uh both in terms of is
it covering the story correctly as well
as is the pros good enough for us like
does it sound good so for instance I
read this paragraph here the fluorescent
lights flicker as I drag my feet across
the precinct floor making my way to my
desk my shoulders slump forward as I
drop into my chair the worn leather
squeaking and protest I could maybe
enhance this a little bit to say nearly
falling out of it as the force of my
desent strains its suspension and then
we could go to a new paragraph and say
everything was old here I try to focus
on the stack of case files on my desk
but they all blur together everything
blurs together without my morning fuel
yeah I'm not sure I like this sentence I
think you could actually just leave it
off and a lot of working with AI is
trimming it in places where it's not
doing a good job or adding little bits
of usually more character moments uh
thoughts that they're going through deep
point of view that kind of thing but
assuming you've gone through all of this
and you're happy with the results the
next step is to write your next scene
beat so we could say
Martinez says he knows of a new coffee
shop that just opened in a nearby town
it's only a 10 minute drive instead of
20 Candice likes this idea and decides
to go visit she says she'll be back in
30 minutes and to tell the Chief if he
asks okay so then we just go to general
purpose and and use the same uh model
again that we've been using Martinez
perks up snapping his fingers oh wait I
forgot to tell you new place just opened
in Cedar Grove right off the highway
Cedar Grove I left my hat that's what 10
minutes away if that next to the old
hardware store and it's really adding in
a lot of detail here that I didn't put
in my prompt which I love some of that's
not going to be what you're envisioning
but this could be actually a good way to
discover interesting things and that is
the name of this method is this is the
Discovery writing method this is how you
actually go through and write a book
piece by piece without doing any of the
prep work or anything if you just want
to get right into things you can let me
now show you how to do this for
non-fictions and we're going to start
again instead of deleting it I'm going
to put my own name in there Jason and
I'm going to say Jason is the writer of
this nonfiction book on its part Memoir
and part selfimprovement
book so I'm really only just
establishing myself as the writer of the
words that are going to be coming out of
this and we're going to go back to the
settings and just make sure that I'm
listed here as the character we're going
to put this in past tense now but leave
it at first person because I am the
actual person writing these words and so
from here we're going to start a
non-fiction book about food addiction
which is something that I you know work
with a little bit and so we'll just say
something like talk about how I was lost
in the Addiction eating myself to death
talk about how it feels like I'm out of
control and that nothing not even
fullness can stop me from eating okay
this is how I would start a non-fiction
book is really get started into like the
worst moment imaginable like talk about
the problem and really Hammer home
before I then talk about the solution so
from here I would just go and select the
same prompt or a different prompt that
you may have created and I'll use 3.5
Sonet again I stared at the empty Pizza
Box on my coffee table my stomach
stretched and aching the grease stained
cardboard mocked me a Silent Witness to
another night of mindless consumption 3
hours ago I'd promised myself I would
only eat two slices now the whole pie
was gone along with half a bag of chips
and a pint of ice cream and it goes on
so yeah so this is good from like a
memoir point of view a good way to start
a non-fiction book if we were to start a
new chapter we could call this chapter
the solution and let's say we wanted to
write less from a memoir type of point
of view and more more from like here are
the actual solutions that we wanted to
go with I could just put in a scene beat
and say walk through the steps to
overcoming food addiction which are and
then I would put in bullet points get
clear on what you are eating every day
eat sugar or refined flour as these are
the most triggering write down what you
will eat the day before
Etc and I could go on and on but U from
here I'll just say generate pros and in
this case we're not necessarily doing it
from a memoir point of view we're giving
it actual information okay so actually
what it was giving me was still in the
kind of narrative point of view so I had
to modify my prompt here to make it so
it's a little bit more information
focused so now the prompt says now stop
writing from a narrative Memoir point of
view and talk to the reader and walk
them through the steps to overcome food
addiction which are 1 2 3 make sure to
use headings for each speak directly to
the reader and from here now I can go
through and write these words and it'll
be a little bit better all right it
still gave me a little bit of an
introduction here that was still in the
narrative format I could easily validate
this and edit that out but it does get
to it here it says get clear on your
daily food intake listen you can't fix
what you don't acknowledge pull out your
phone right now and write down
everything you ate today everything
those three M&M's from your co-worker
desk write them down a handful of chips
you grabbed while cooking include them
and so forth you could also create a
prompt that's specifically designed to
write non-fiction I actually have a
prompt like that that I've created it's
basically a it's a copy of the general
purpose system prompt that I've modified
for non-fiction specifically so there's
a lot of flexibility here you can
definitely do non-fiction inside of
Novel crafter novel crafter is really
more of a tool for long form uh books or
any kind of writing really in a long
format but again this is the simple way
to do it this is the way to go just you
know one step at a time and writing it
just by the seat of your pants and so
let's talk now about the other way of
doing this which is to plan everything
out ahead of time using a method that I
call the fractal technique so for this
we're actually going to go to chat GPT
and this is chat gpt's basic interface
as you can tell there's a lot less going
on in chat GPT than novel crafter and
that's in part a good thing because it
makes things really simple and easy some
people will tell you not to use a chat
Bots like this because they're almost
too simple and easy and you lose a
little bit of that flexibility and the
control that you can have have I think
that you should be taking a Best of Both
Worlds approach which is why I recommend
one chat bot and one specialized tool
because sometimes you do want more
fine-tune control over everything and
sometimes you just need something simple
that makes it quicker and easier to do
and so I think having access to one
chatbot and one specialized tool is the
best way to go so here in chat GPT we're
going to start doing this fractal
technique which is to start small and to
build from there I'm going to do this in
two different chats one for fiction one
for non-fiction but it's essentially the
same process process so we'll start here
by using this standard brainstorming
prompt where I'm going to ask it for a
mythical urban fantasy story and it's
going to give me a bunch of ideas and by
the way if you are interested in this
prompt that I just used I have all of
the prompts that I use regularly in a
spreadsheet you can get that for free by
going to the link down below and signing
up for my email list you'll not only get
my prompts but you'll get an outlining
template that I have which I'll explain
in a second but anyway we've got a whole
bunch of ideas once again the validation
process is important and you need to go
through these ideas and carefully select
the one that you want assuming you don't
already have an idea for your book
already which may be the case you might
not need to do this step let's say we
like this one right here a private
investigator who can see the future must
stop a prophecy from destroying New York
but every clue reveals she might be the
cause of the city's Doom that's actually
not a bad beginner prompt for a story so
we can go ahead and select that the next
step of course is to populate this world
a little bit you want to make sure we
have the characters down that we're
interested in the world building a lot
of that stuff needs to be finalized
before we can start on the outline now
if you want to see what the AI would
come up with you can just go with the
outline step anyway but sometimes I like
to say okay let's go with number one
brainstorm three characters three
important World building elements and
the climax of the story I usually like
to include the climax of the story
because I want to know where the story
is going and that will actually help the
AI to build a better outline later
because it already knows where the
outline is going so with this little
prompt you can go ahead and say okay
here's our main character Cassidy Lane
Eli crane detective Maria Voss giving us
some World building elements here
related to the story and it gives us the
climax so once again you're going to
want to go through and really validate
this and make sure it's up to your
storytelling standards some of this is
going to be overly generic and not
actually really interesting so you want
to go through and check that so assuming
you've edited all of this you're going
to want to take the edited version and
include it here and say here is my
edited version and then move on to the
next step but just for demonstration
purposes I'm going to use this exactly
as it gave it to me just keep in mind
you're probably going to want to
validate it further to make the quality
even higher otherwise you're going to be
left with a very poor quality book all
right this next prompt is a very long
one and the reason is because I'm going
to give it a massive outline template I
find the outline templates help to help
it get structured although this stage is
going to require quite a bit of
validation so let me show you what I
mean this is my 40 chapter plot module
and this document that you're looking at
right now is another one that you can
get for free when you sign up for my
email list so definitely go check that
out below but I'm just going to take
this entire outline template as you can
see here it's very long it's for 40
chapters 41 actually and I'm going to
say using the following outline template
create a full outline for this book then
I usually like to have something in
there that says the summary for each
chapter should have
specific details rather than vague
Illusions to what should happen write it
as though you were going to hand it off
to a ghost writer to write the first
draft right and then I just put in the
entire template that I just copied and
it's actually done something that chaty
PT does specifically which is to create
a canvas where you can actually modify
this a little bit more to your liking
which is a useful feature so now we've
got the outline for act one with the
prologue being the opening image here
the city of New York is shrouded in dark
ominous clouds time fractures Ripple
through the skyline like glass shards a
shadowy figure Eli crane stands on a
rooftop watching his buildings flicker
between existence and non-existence he
whispers only destruction can save us
now the skyline collapses into chaos
okay uh this sounds like more like the
kind of thing that you would see in a
dream sequence so maybe we would add
that in we can put the chapter ends with
Cassidy waking up from a nightmare right
something like that and then the next
chapter starts with the unusual day a
grimy Brooklyn office Cassidy Lane a
private investigator in her 30s with a
haunted look reviews a case File while
trying to ignore flashes of the future
in her mind her Visions are chaotic and
unclear and so forth and it goes through
the entire thing now this is definitely
something where you would want to
validate this and as you can see for
some reason the summary of each chapter
got really small by the end of the thing
and it didn't actually finish it so we
could ask it please continue with Act 2
B and act 3 now if you wanted you could
actually just go one chapter at a time I
actually like to do this because I enjoy
the outlining process the most and so I
will usually write my own outlines and
only consult AI if I am stuck on a
particular chapter and I want to
brainstorm ideas for what should happen
just in the next chapter I'm not trying
to do the whole chapter at once usually
when you try to do the whole chapter at
once it kind of messes a whole lot of
things up so what I might do is I'll
have a separate document and I'll try to
get it to write the entire outline but
then I'll just pick and choose the
elements that I like the most then feed
that back into the AI and say Here's
what I've got for the outline so far can
you fill in the gaps and then it does
that and then I pick and choose from
that which parts I like the most and so
on there's a lot of different ways that
you can go about it the point is we are
developing our outline at this stage and
from here you could stay inside a chat
GPT for the rest of this but I would
actually recomend commend that at this
point or earlier potentially if you want
uh we move over into novel crafter or
Raptor or whatever tool you're using for
the remaining section and so let's say
this is our prologue right from here we
can go to novel crafter and I'm going to
show you a feature I didn't show you
before which is the plan section and in
the plan section we can say okay this is
the prologue and this is the uh we'll
say chapter one right and you keep on
going for the full chapters that you've
got there and now from chat GPT you can
copy over what you've got here and put
that summary in the prologue here grab
what we've got for chapter one put that
into chapter one and so now novel
crafter is going to be able to look at
this and understand what's going to
happen broadly in the entire chapter
another thing you might want to do at
this point is put in your characters so
for instance we have these characters
that the AI came up with for Cassidy
Lane so we would just come over here
create a character named Cassidy Lane
and put information that the AI gave us
if you validated make sure to put
anything you have in there as well I
will often write these myself because
there are specific things I want the AI
to know I want it to know like what does
she look like I want it to know what her
dialogue and speech patterns are because
those affect the way it writes but just
for now for demonstration purpose we'll
just use what it gave us and then we
would go through and make more
characters for these other characters
that it invented here as well as maybe
some of these World building elements
for instance here if you select new
entry you can create other things
besides characters you've got location
objects lore Etc so some of those World
building elements might go into lore or
into locations whatever the case may be
the point is you just want to fill this
out with all of this information now you
have to be careful with this because a
lot of authors can get stuck at this
stage trying to make all of their
elements perfect so that the AI knows
everything it needs to know about their
books the fact of the matter is you
don't actually need the AI to know
everything about your books all it needs
to know is what happens next and that is
something that you are ultimately
responsible in in forming it it doesn't
necessarily need to know all of your
world building all of the time it just
needs to know the small section that
happens next so now that we filled out
novel crafter the next part is to do
similar to what we just did in the
discovery writing phase you create a
scene beat and then you write what it is
should happen in the next section of the
text now you might have no idea what
should happen in the next scene and so
you can go back to chat GPT here copy in
the text of the first chapter and say
please break this down into and you can
give it a number I usually go between 12
and 20 so we'll say right in the middle
we'll do 15 Steps for this scene to
break it down into more specific details
about what happens in the scene
something along those lines there are a
number of ways that you can structure
that but then you just paste in the text
for the outline and it's going through
and actually giving me the 15-step
breakdown of the scene and I'm not
actually sure I like this establishing
shot but we can maybe take both of these
and just copy them into novel crafter so
once again we are moving from something
small to something a little bit bigger
just to kind of Flesh things out one
step at a time so this is what we call
the scene beat stage some people have
different names for it I think actually
the word scene beat is maybe a little
misleading but it's essentially just a
more detailed summary of the scene and
I'm only taking a few bits of it for
this next stage although you could put
all of the scene breakdown in there and
just ask it to write a really long scene
but I like to do it in smaller chunks
let me show you how this works so we'll
just use the general standard prompt
that we have here and use the 3.5 Sonet
like we've been doing before I'm not
saying you have to do it that way but
it's those are probably my favorite ways
to go and it'll write the beginning of
the scene and it's actually writing from
my perspective again because I forgot to
remove myself as a character so but it
actually created some interesting Pros
as a result says as I document these
extraordinary events I must emphasize
that what occurred in New York City on
September 15th 2023 IED all conventional
explanation from my vantage point at the
observation deck of the Empire State
Building I witnessed the transformation
of our City's familiar Skyline that
challenged the very foundations of
reality not perfect but interesting
because it's writing from the
perspective of someone documenting it
almost in a non-fiction perspective so
that was a little happy accident there
which you will find happens a lot with
AI and it went through and wrote the
whole scene and so the next step would
be to take the next couple of Beats
whether you write them yourself or
whether you use what AI gave you and you
continue on in the format until the
chapter is complete once again you want
to go through that validation process to
make sure everything is up to Snuff you
want to do this at the earlier
brainstorming and outlining phases
because if you don't do that then you're
essentially building a book on a flawed
foundation and you want to do it at the
pros level too because otherwise it's
going to sound a little bit like AI
writing which to people like myself who
have been working with AI for a long
time is really easy to spot and so you
want to make sure you add your own
little human touch in there add some
character moments make sure that
everything everything looks good I also
know people that will actually write a
very rough draft of the story with just
a little bit of dialogue a little bit of
description but not a whole lot and they
will give that to the AI and ask it to
expand it with more description to
improve the writing and that is often a
good way to go as well but regardless of
whatever tool or technique that you use
the point is this does take a little bit
more time than I think a lot of people
think I think a lot of people think it's
just you push a button and out pops a
book but really that's not the case in
order to do this right you have to be
really thinking through all of the ideas
you have to be validating the results
it's still very much your vision too cuz
I imagine most of you already have ideas
of what you want to do and so going
through this process with your own ideas
rather than just a random idea pulled
out of chat GPT like I did in this
demonstration is going to make it even
more like it's your baby right now I'm
going to briefly walk you through the
non-fiction process it's basically the
same thing but a little bit different I
already know the topic of this book it's
going to be a memoir SL self-improvement
book about struggles with food addiction
and so I'm going to actually jump
straight to the outlining phase and say
I want to write a book about food
addiction it would be part Memoir part
selfhelp book please give me a list of
possible chapter topics so instead of
trying to outline this from a fiction
perspective we're just asking for a list
of topics that should be included in
this book and in that sense it's a very
easier process in a lot of ways and so
it gives me a whole bunch of things
Memoir Focus chapters okay I like that
to kind of go through my own story I
might even want to layer these so that
I'm going alternating between a memoir
Focus chapter and a self-help Focus
chapter I've seen books written that way
and then we have the self-help Focus
chapters understanding food addiction
identifying your triggers Etc and going
through that and I could say okay this
is really great or it might give me some
ideas like oh actually we should have a
chapter about this I might go through
some of these chapters and say well that
chapter actually does doesn't fit so
once again you go through the validation
process and then you break it down into
the next step which is to instead of
creating scene beats for a chapter we're
creating a more detailed outline of a
given chapter and so for instance let's
say we wanted to flesh out this chapter
right here I would say flesh out this
chapter to include more specific
information about what should be
included in the chapter and so here we
go so the chapter is about understanding
food addiction what it is and how it
affects the brain introduction to
defining food addiction clarifying what
the food addiction is explain that food
addiction is characterized by compulsive
consumption of certain foods types of
foods involved Etc sugar salt fat
processed carbohydrates yep that's all
true now the validation process for
non-fiction is slightly different in the
sense that you're going to have to fact
check everything that's the biggest
thing that you're going to have to deal
with when writing non-fiction make sure
that everything you say is accurate now
you could provide the facts yourself you
can say here are the statistics about
food addiction and include those in your
prompts so that the AI gets it right
that's a great way to go about it or you
can use a tool like perplexity as a
research tool to find all of that
information that you need and the nice
thing about perplexity is it will give
you sources so you can fact check
everything right there inside of its own
ecosystem and I haven't talked about
perplexity yet because I don't use it
too often for writing types of work but
it can be a fantastic research tool and
I actually use it more than Google so
for instance if I wanted to have a list
of statistics about food addiction I
could just ask it give me a detailed
list of statistics about food addiction
and then I hit go and it gives me a very
detailed list looks up some sources now
some of these sources might not be good
sources so you do need to make sure you
go through them but it gives me a bunch
of of things here 14% of adults and 12%
of children in the United States meet
criteria for food addiction the global
prevailance of ultra processed food
addiction is estimated at 14% of adults
and 15% of Youth one in eight Americans
over 50 Etc risk factors women age 50 to
64 you know all of this stuff and so
this this is great information and great
research that I could use in my
non-fiction book this is kind of
essentially the same step as fleshing
out your characters in your world
building and fiction but in the case of
non-fiction you're just assembling
research information and perplexity is a
great tool to do that so once you have
all of this stuff you can go back to
your chapter outlines make sure they are
accurate make sure they have all the
correct information and then you move on
to writing the pros and that process is
pretty much exactly the same as what
I've shown you so far so I'm not going
to go over it again the final step for
both fiction and non-fiction is that you
just continue this process until you
have fleshed out the entire book it's
still going to take a long time but the
best thing about writing with AI is not
necessarily the time it saves you it
does save you some time but really the
best thing about it is that it saves you
headache because now you're not having
to hold all of this information in your
head you're not having to make tiny
micro decisions about every single
sentence that you write that's the one
of the things that burned me out about
writing is that there's so much that
goes into it and so this allows you to
kind of have a second brain to work with
you to help you create that initial
draft and allow you to edit it and
validate it instead of coming up with it
all yourself which can be a real minds
saer and one of the reasons why I enjoy
working with AI so much but that's not
to say that you have to be using AI for
every step of the process like I've
shown you as I've already mentioned
outlining is my favorite part so I tend
to do that myself and this is where I
think AI can shine I think you should
use it to lift up your weaknesses and
augment your strengths and when I mean
by this is if you get joy out of writing
the first draft of your book then by all
means continue writing the first draft
of your book but I think you will find
that AI can help you at every step of
the writing process because writing is
not just putting down that first draft
it is brainstorming it is character
development it is writing it is revising
it is more revising it is marketing
there's all kinds of different pieces of
the process and I'm sure at some point
one of those parts of the process is
something that is not enjoyable for you
that's where you should should really
Embrace AI to help you out and then
spend more time doing the things that
you actually love to do and that's a
great way for AI to allow you to play to
your own strengths and to help lift up
your weaknesses now we've covered a lot
in this video but one thing we didn't
really cover is the basics of AI and
just how AI works and if you want to
know more about this I did do a video
recently about that that you can check
out so you'll have that foundational
expertise that can really help your
writing shine so go check that out and I
will see you in the next video